will joining me now is our defense and
security analyst Professor Michael Clark
welcome back to you Michael and
obviously concerned about the zaparita
nuclear power plant but in the meantime
there's plenty of other things going on
out there including an apparent drone
attack inside Russia again yes I know
the tempo of events is increasing all
the time so overnight it looks as if
there was a drone attack at krasnadar
the Russians are saying I think it was a
drone I'm pretty sure it probably was it
hasn't been illuminated the biggest fire
you've ever seen at a Refinery there are
lots of them but it's a huge set of
refineries but nevertheless it makes the
point and interestingly cross Nadar is
not so far from Nova rosisk and that is
where the all the oil exports go from
Russia into the before the Black Sea and
four ports in the Mediterranean and
further afield so it's a really
important port and also at Nova resisk
the Russians have now got most of the
Black Sea Fleet base there because it
was too dangerous to leave them at
sevastopol which is on that sort of
Southwestern tip of Crimea so they've
moved most of the fleet to Nova Rosie's
so this has become in a very important
port in the heart of Russia and even to
hit you know a few miles away the
refineries is picking away at Russia's
infrastructure and it's making the point
to the Russians and the very least even
though this is as I say it's not a major
fight it was put out pretty quickly but
it makes the Russians have to bring some
resources back to defend these
facilities for the future that's
interesting and not the only drone
attack of course we've seen in recent
days so how are these attacks playing
into the overall conflict yeah we're
starting to build up quite a quite a
record of them now so this is the third
of May some weeks ago which was the
attack of two drones on the on the
Kremlin it was a dome of the Senate
Palace within the Kremlin Fortress
within the walls uh two drones 16
minutes apart both from different
directions didn't do any damage unless
they may have hurt Two Fellas who were
walking up the ladder onto the Dome
after the first attack to assess how bad
the damage was they might have been
killed or injured in the second attack
we don't know but that was on the the
third of May then the 30th of May
yesterday
there were a series of attacks some have
said there were more than 20 drones
involved some 30 some 13 but the
Russians have confirmed this number so
we've got eight confirmed downings of of
drones almost certainly these were aimed
for Central Moscow and they didn't make
it although some of them came down in
the elite District in the northwest of
Moscow where all the uh the elite the
oligarchs live including Putin that's
his overnight residence that's where he
sleeps doesn't sleep in the Kremlin he
sleeps there so it's possible that that
was intended as a symbolic Target but
all these are hitting residential areas
which is not a good idea it's they are
not legitimate uh military targets and
then of course meanwhile the Russians
have been hitting Dro hitting
Kiev and other cities in Ukraine with
drones repeatedly so after the uh the
10th of of October last year they began
a series of fortnightly big attacks 16
15 of those then the 16th iteration
began at the beginning of May and then
they went to attack the be 48 Hours
pretty well and in the last apart from
today they then had three attacks in 24
hours on all these various cities in
Ukraine so the Russians are really
stepping up their drone attacks and
their missile attacks partly to test the
Ukrainian defenses I suspect and also to
see if they can run down their
ammunition to actually wear out the
amount of ammunition that the ukrainians
have got and we know that in certain
respects they may be running low on some
things and they'll need more supplies
quite quickly so that's a tax on the air
what about what's happening on the
ground what's happening in back moot for
example yeah everyone's waiting on the
ground to see what's going to happen
next a very good example Bank was taken
by the Russians by the Wagner group just
over a week ago and the answer is
nothing is happening in your back mode
and that in itself is very interesting
there's some artillery jewels to the
west but the Russians are conducting
what's known as a rotation in place so
Wagner moving out and the moving out
between now and the fifth of June
according to them and they're being
replaced by who you know who is going in
to take their places in Bank mode itself
and what we know is that places being
taken partly by a group called The
savesky Battalion who a group of
volunteers sorry the the nevsky
Battalion group of volunteers another
group called the uh the first wolves and
they are a group of sabotage Specialists
and then some of the militias from the
Donetsk People's Republic who are not
renowned for their military capability
so when we see the units that seem to be
going in to take over from Wagner
they're not very good they're not really
big Frontline units and that tells me or
indicates to me that the Russians don't
expect to be attacked in back mode
because there's no strategic value it
never had strategic value they fought
for a year over it symbolically but they
don't think that the ukrainians will
attack them and I don't think the
Ukraine's will attack them there either
because it won't do them any good all
the Strategic areas are north and south
of bakmut and that's where we might
expect to see some movement so what
we're seeing now in these days before
this offensive begins don't know how
long it will take but we're into the
final days before the event so I'm
fairly convinced we're seeing Russian
commanders make their decisions they're
placing their forces where they think
they'll be needed and bringing their
reserves to the areas where they think
they'll have to be and I keep saying
it's a bit like a it's a bit like a
roulette wheel the wheel has been
turning now somebody spun the wheel and
the p is bouncing around so now is the
time to place your bets put your units
where you think they will do the most
good and when the wheel stops turning
we'll find out we will and you think
that stays away I'm gonna wait and see
Michael thanks very much indeed